brian experts shedding some light on the
opioid crisis that is sweeping this
country the mob museum hosting a panel
discussion tonight with journalist sam
quinones now he's been chronicling the
issue for decades and says it's now at
levels our country has never seen tens
of millions of pills are said to be
flowing into this country from mexico by
the cartels and most of the pills are
being sold to people not realizing
exactly what they're buying
they're looking for new ways of
packaging it so to speak of delivering
it and and these new
uh counterfeit
uh pills are now
everywhere and they're extraordinarily
deadly and frequently so because the
people who are buying them very often
don't know what they're buying they
think they're buying a legitimate pain
pill and it turns out to only have
fentanyl and kills them
now earlier this summer metro police
rolling out a social media campaign
warning teenagers about these dangerous
pills in 2020 and 2021 16 people younger
than 18 died from a fentanyl overdose